welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid so Trident 3b asked can you do one
on gravity I have yet to see an
explanation that really describes how
gravity exercises a polling force
well Trident that's tricky but I like a
challenge ok first let's start from a
more familiar place you've got freefall
which we've seen before
you've got projectiles which is kind of
like freefall but they move along the
ground too like this this or this or
this
unfortunately air makes both of those
really complicated and this isn't a
video about air so let's ignore it
the faster you launch something the
farther it goes until eventually you
missed the earth completely this is what
we call in orbit all of this is
described pretty well by Newton's
universal law of gravity which states
two things one all masses attract and
two they attract each other more when
they're closer
that was like 350 years ago did you even
read Triton's question let's take
another look Oh oops okay if you stop to
think about it I guess it does seem kind
of magical this law didn't turn out to
be so universal either there were a few
things that couldn't explain like
Mercury's crazy orbit in 1915 Einstein
proposed a different model for gravity
call general relativity it suggested
that space itself was something tangible
then it could be bent stretched and
twisted if you've heard of it you've
probably seen a picture like this or a
demo like this lies all lies
this diagram is actually drawn using
Newton's law of gravity not Einstein's
the only way this demo even works is if
the earth pulls everything down I mean
they're decent for a quick explanation
but gravity is way cooler than that
according to general relativity masses
don't actually attract one another there
is no force what that's crazy yeah it is
remembered Newton's first law of motion
it says that no force means you move in
a straight line at a steady speed if
gravity isn't a force then why does the
moon do this around the earth
WTF universe believe it or not this
comes down to what you mean by a
straight line this is a line it looks
pretty straight but how can you know for
sure you can pull out a ruler but that
assumes the ruler is straight we need
something that's a little more absolute
so here's the earth in the moon there
are many paths between them but the
straightest one is the one that takes
the least time to travel dude what are
you getting at well we said gravity
isn't a force right and things go in a
straight line when there isn't a force
so this is a straight line it just
doesn't look straight anymore because
the earth is there we call them least
time paths still with me okay good
without a force any object will travel
along a path that takes the least time
mass just changes what those paths look
like and the bigger the mass the bigger
change a huge star can turn paths that
look like this into paths that look like
this these lease time paths also depend
on the speed of the thing that's moving
the faster it's going the less is
affected but there is no speed that is
unaffected light is affected by gravity
so yeah
gravity's crazy as gravity ever gotten
the best of you please share in the
comments and if you want to yell at me
for hurting your brain you can share
that down there too and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
you